we will
of course return to this maybe next week
because we will of course know a lot
more this is really a very
new uh story
but
you know i think everybody is rushing to
formulate a position over what has been
called new and omicron i must say i
don't like these terms i am beginning to
feel
that whatever is true of the actual
biological phenomenon there is clearly a
narrative phenomenon riding on it and i
wonder
if omicron is not
part of a
slick presentation that is supposed to
get us to feel clever for being in on
the new nomenclature which you have to
learn if it's not a little bit like
ordering you know a uh
a vente americano with room for cream
right and the idea is you feel clever
for
knowing that venti is code for whatever
the hell size that is which i don't know
because i'm not 20. what it's going to
be 20 isn't it i don't know i mean it
sounds like the number 20 to me it does
sound like the number two it hadn't even
occurred to me i've never actually gone
to starbucks but i think that's a
starbucks thing and that sounds like 20.
20 what ounces yeah okay all right that
would be cool all right
um i think i'm gonna go get one that
sounds kind of good
but um
but in any case some things we just
don't know at all yeah i worry about a
number of things here and i think people
should start tracking the story but you
got to track it as two different stories
one there is a biological phenomenon
presumably there is a new variant right
it came from somewhere it does something
it has characteristics i think people
have
jumped to the conclusion that because it
appears to be highly infectious that
this is a disaster now it could be a
disaster
but i don't think we know that until we
know how virulent it is right in other
words
there has been too much talk since the
beginning of the pandemic of oh
viruses tend to evolve to become
less damaging to their hosts there's
truth in this evolutionarily but all
bets are off in the case of a virus that
likely came from a laboratory experiment
designed to enhance it in certain
certain ways but nonetheless
it is possible
that a variant that is
more infectious but less destructive
could actually rescue us from our
terrible public health
uh
response
right not saying that's what's happening
i have no idea this is far too new but i
do think that that
you at least want to have it whoa slow
down we want to know more about this
variant before we know whether
we know how to feel about it yeah um if
it were
more transmissible um but less virulent
doing less damage to the hosts that it
infects uh this might actually be the
thing that ends that ends this hell that
we are all forced to live in at the
moment um and um
it is also true that so that you know
they're just there are a number of
things that are true of earlier variants
that may or may not be true of this
later one and um some you know among
other things things like degree of
transmissibility and
amount of harm that it does you know
but amount of harm that it does
per different demographic groups so we
know that the versions of covet that we
are more familiar with
uh
preferentially go after
you the older you are the sicker you are
um and then there are a few other
demographic factors like you're more
likely to get sick if you're male if you
have dark skin
um and that there are a number and you
know if you're institutionalized if you
don't get outside very much
um and then there are you know the kinds
of sickness um include many but
especially things like uh
lung and kidney disease
and some kinds of cancers seem to um
really correspond with with bad outcomes
so you know does the new variant change
any of those truths and um you know i
think as as we have talked about
privately one of the things one of the
ways that it it could be different
um for reasons that we aren't getting
into like you know why might it have
changed but you know one of the things
that would be very dire for all of us is
if it started uh to
infect and really cause serious harm to
younger people the way that it has not
um hardly begun to do yet right right
which is actually a prediction of gear
uh vandenbosch's model yeah um which is
that it would expand it's expand uh the
populations into which it's it's
it's moving although um
you know it could also spread and sort
of become background and not uh and and
not to be doing the kinds of harm that
it has yet to begin to begin to be doing
to young people i mean there's also the
question and
i don't i haven't really not looked on
this new variant hardly at all but i
wondered with regard to the delta and
the other variants what what you and i
have been wondering for decades now with
regard to boundaries between categories
and biological systems right
that you know species is a a necessary
concept with which evolutionary
biologists divide up the world but that
doesn't mean that the organisms in
question recognize those boundaries as
such
and you know what on what basis
are new variants being
described and carved out and named and
given that i am certain that you could
make an argument a compelling argument
to name new variants in a lot of places
that they haven't been named at a lot of
moments that they haven't been named
that raises the question of what other
factors for instance political factors
are going into the naming of new
variants of particular places of
particular times yeah in this case um i
think the the argument that this is
indeed a new variant worthy of naming um
appears to be
almost absurdly strong by virtue of how
many different mutations we are talking
about
now i will also say so but doesn't that
raise the question of whether or not um
so relate relate to this party and it's
been you know it's been
there are you know three intermediate
forms that we didn't name that have been
out there circulating and it's been
accumulating mutations and now we
finally see it in these in these
patients and oh now we're going to name
it because we see a clear boundary but
at the point that you see a clear
boundary that suggests that there is
some time between now and the last time
you looked
well that's part of the problem here is
that so far and again we're nowhere in
terms of uh time from our awareness of
this thing so you know it's it's very
early to be discussing anything but
there is something very weird about this
variant and
what it implies about what must have
happened evolutionarily in fact
it might not even add up at all right so
i don't know what that is do you want to
say anything more about yeah i do you've
got a bunch of different mutations
right many of which appear to be
uh
alarmingly well targeted from the point
of view of escaping potentially both
natural immunity and vaccine immunity
the problem is
that doesn't tell
a very clean story about where such a
thing would have come from because in
general a new mutation that created some
ability to escape from some kind of
widely existing immunity would tend to
bring with it a generic random
background right the critter that
happened to have the mutation that
happened to be good at escaping either
vaccine immunity or natural immunity
right would be
effectively random with respect to the
rest of what it contained in its genome
so the idea that suddenly we're
confronted with something that has a
bunch of useful mutations suggests some
process that isn't described here
what's more as i understand the spike
protein isn't modified
right in fact the spike protein looks
primitive
it looks like it
stretches back and has experienced no
evolution over many months so
i don't know what to make of any of this
um i will say it's very confusing well
you know it may or may not be confusing
i think the problem is when we were
talking about lab leak
there was an explanation you know what
was the intermediate host where's the
intermediate host right how did this
thing get from horseshoe bats to people
and make all of these different changes
and the answer was well you're looking
for a population of animals you should
be looking for a laboratory right yeah
if you're looking for a laboratory
intermediate host got it okay laboratory
has complex processes it has things it's
trying to accomplish so anyway i don't
know why this story doesn't make sense
maybe next week we'll know why it does
make sense
but so far what i've heard is the
invocation of an untreated
hiv positive person who would therefore
have an unusual immune system and
effectively what's being suggested is
that this one individual constitutes an
incredible gain of function
de facto gain a function experiment
there's a patient zero that has been oh
we don't know the patient but that's
this has been a model okay oh okay
uh a hypothetical patient zero that was
a hiv positive but out there in the
world
patient in whom this might have
originated right but i got to tell you
this is one of these things sometimes
when molecular biologists
there's this nasty habit they have
because all biologists are in theory
working in an evolutionary realm there's
sort of this nasty habit of imagining
there isn't much to understand about the
way evolution works survival of the
fittest that's about it right and so
when molecular biologists come up with
something they will very often
um toss out an evolutionary explanation
for it that isn't very high quality and
doesn't stand up to even a little bit of
scrutiny and i wonder you know we saw
this
um
last week
with the suggestion that what happened
to sars kovi 2 in japan was that the
virus thought better of it and collapsed
right
and do i mean there was a lot of like
adaptive language arm-waving stuff which
people imagine is what we do over an
evolution space it was like you know
selective forces went boom or something
like it was it was insanely mystical
thinking but you know again in the guise
of sort of a sciencey looking set of
people
and it it really just didn't make sense
well let's put it this way it could make
sense given another factor that was
never discussed right you would need
something to push the virus in this
direction before it became unstable in
other words
you know
our audience probably will mostly not
know that my expertise is trade-offs if
that's what i did my dissertation on so
maybe at one moment i was the world's
leading expert on biological trade-offs
but the point is
you can sometimes borrow what cost
that's a good joke
you can sometimes push
a critter including a virus into a
corner right so for example he's not
talking about it for i mean he's not
talking literally i've never seen him
push organisms into corners
uh
i mean occasionally you've had to corner
a mouse actually like can we just get
this out of the house
or a dog if you're going to
you know clean out its ears but that's
true
but in any case let's just take an
example metaphorical cornering of
organisms
so there was a result years ago some
people will have seen news reports of it
because it was of course oh very
tantalizing are we about to cure aging
but um there was a simple alteration
that was made to the model organism worm
c elegans
that caused them to live much longer
like a double its lifespan right and i i
saw that and i was like yeah okay but
what capacity of this creature did you
just turn off because if it were true
that you could just simply make them
live twice as long with a simple genetic
alteration selection would have done it
so the lady worms look at those worms
and say oh no oh no oh no i've seen this
before
but and in this case we now know what it
was which was they borrowed from its
ability to endure famine
right
and so the point is did you just improve
them as long as they live in an abundant
world right exactly as long as they
lived in the lab it was cool
so the question is is there something
another version of this you can see with
the with the way hiv was ultimately
managed that it's managed with a triple
drug cocktail another reason that that
works is because you can put the virus
in a bind right each of these drugs has
an effect and basically if it
evolves to compensate for one it makes
itself more vulnerable to the others and
so it's you know you can drive it back
and forth between these you know right
keep it keep it on its feet as it were
and so something in japan could have
driven the virus to make a bad choice
about how much mutation to accept and
then it became incoherent but you need
the something and the something could
you know i'm not saying it is but it
could be something like the drug that
shall not be named
right that could potentially push a
virus into making compromises that were
not wise in the end and caused it to be
defeated by immunity or whatever
but the basic point is you need
something else for that story to make
any sense otherwise you're just a hand
waving right yeah and in this case this
idea of oh an immunocompromised person
is the reason that this virus has you
know a bunch of different clever
alterations
right that sounds like another really
hand wavy argument
right
and so i remain to be convinced that
there's any explanation at all that
would have done what we've so far been
told has happened to this variant and in
light of that i would just advise a
couple of different kinds of caution
one we need to separate our
understanding of what is actually true
of this variant from our understanding
of what we are being told right there's
some gap between what's true and it will
always be even if the people doing this
are
are well intentioned but this is always
the problem i mean i i feel like this is
really to some degree always been the
problem with media with journalism you
know presumably tracing as far back as
any kind of journalism has existed that
there is some truth and given that much
the journalism reports on there it that
truth may be social at some level which
means that there really are different
versions of of a story which seem
incompatible but both of which really do
reflect what two different observers saw
of the thing
but that
put all that aside the journalist who is
writing the story
is writing a story about
the thing and the story about the thing
is never the same thing as the thing
right you know it's it's it's a
journalistic version of the map is not
the territory
and right now and pretending pretending
that it is is um dangerous and i think
you know for anyone paying even the
slightest bit of attention during kovid
it's just become completely clear that
this is true all the time there's in
fact no way so you're asking
all of us here what i heard you just
asked was you know we need to keep
careful track of the distance the
distance between what is true about this
new variant what we are being told is
true but how can we possibly do that
well well what no
what you want you're going to have to
simplify it even even those of us who
are trying to get this stuff precisely
right have to simplify it even to just
discuss it the point is you do not want
a systematic bias between what is
actually true and understood and the
simplification that you're offering in
order to discuss it right you want you
want it to be a reduction in resolution
but not a reduction in accuracy right
and this is not what we are getting we
are getting a landscape in which dots
are being arrayed in front of you so
that you will put them together just so
and feel clever as you announce the
answer right that is a very dangerous
situation to be in right and it's
unforgivable from the point of view of
what this is doing to people's ability
to calculate what is in their interest
and what they should fear and all of
that we are being manipulated by those
who want us to be fearful and the
problem is they are manipulating us to
be fearful of something that is indeed
frightening right they're amping up our
fear about the wrong things and to a
degree that isn't warranted but
nonetheless
it's not as if the fear is all
unwarranted yep
but in any case i would say separate out
what we actually know about this
from
the simplified story that we are being
handed that's one thing
and then the other thing is simplify
the medical question
the epidemiological question of this new
variant
and
the
use of this story by
the
uh medical authoritarians
and that's what i'm really concerned
about right am i worried about this new
variant yeah there are things we could
learn about it that would make me much
more relaxed but at the moment i'm
pretty concerned about what i've heard
so far
i am also even more concerned about what
the medical authoritarians are going to
do with that story
right it is going to upend all sorts of
things
including quite possibly the awakening
that people were going through that they
had been misled that they were now being
uh forced to things that didn't make
sense right like boosters right so the
point is
the big danger here is that the new
variant upends
processes it up could upend the
acquisition of natural immunity across
the population it could reset that right
where if we had left the thing
to run its course which i do not
advocate do not think would have been a
good idea but if we had we would be to a
certain place where such a large
fraction of the population had had the
disease that there weren't all that many
vulnerable people did we do this to
ourselves that's the question by by
attempting to make things better did we
make them worse
right that's one possibility and what
are we about to do as we panic over this
new
variant that's the other question and so
i think we need to have a go slow
approach i think we need to to be honest
with you i think we need to resist
letting those who have narratively
backed us into this terrible position
continue to to drive the narrative and
i'm concerned about
new and omicron as
you know part of a pr campaign designed
to make us feel clever as we say
you know scientifically jargony things
to each other so well feel clever
beneath a strong veneer of fear right it
is it is clear that we all need to be
kept afraid in order to be kept
manipulable
and um
looking at this and saying
okay uh better public policy is clearly
necessary you've you know you've
described two reasons to
conclude uh positively that public
policy to date has made things worse
rather than better uh but regardless of
what this is you know take whatever
action you can
to protect yourself and to make the
world a better place but do not succumb
to
oh my god i don't know what this is this
could be terrible and therefore i'm
afraid because it is the it is the
making decisions from fear that does
explain actually a substantial maybe
minority maybe not even of the
extraordinarily bad decisions that we're
seeing people make yep
now uh i this morning decided that i was
going to try a different moniker just so
that i could escape the um for yourself
no i sort of think we ought to generally
adopt it but um anyway i don't i don't a
moniker for yourself no no a moniker for
the new variant oh okay haven't you
heard about the new variant it's gonna
turn planet earth upside down um so i'm
calling it covid22
um
and uh no we're not there yet right
well but the thing is
we're gonna be and it this is you know
the story will mature into 2022.
okay i mean i i guess to be consistent
though it has to be code 21. yeah
because 19 is you know supposedly
discovered on december 31st of 2019 and
of course you know we now have very good
evidence there's it was probably a few
months before that but regardless even
if it was if it was what we were told
and what is still the mainstream story
for a very long time literally the first
case discovered in the last day of 2019
and still got the 19 in its name i hear
ya i hear you but i think kobe 22 is
better
why um
various reasons
uh one there's a catch-22 aspect and two
the story is going to unfold in
you know the fact is covet 19 is a bit
of a weird moniker because most of the
awareness of it doesn't dawn until 2020.
and so
uh in any case i do think we at the very
least need our compelled by your first
reason but not by your second the the
catch-22 uh connection does make it good
but it's not it's not consistent in
terms of naming conventions
yeah i i hear yeah i do i do hear you
but all right um
it's going to be very interesting to see
what this story does i do think the
number one thing we all have to do is
not jump
and keep
separate
analyses for what we are being
manipulated into believing
what we know
and simplifications both natural and
unnatural that are necessary in order to
have the conversation
i will also say
i did have a conversation with chris
martinson this morning it affected my
thinking on this we were on the same
page but anyway we had a back and forth
and so anyway i would like people
to register that he's another excellent
person to be listening to on this topic
if you don't know who i'm talking about
check out peak prosperity sign up for
that channel and uh
i think you'll see the the two channels
are quite compatible and you get a lot
from
[Music]
you